hello everyone welcome to the Laing
focused Channel and my name is Paul
today's topic is the languages of South
Africa the Republic of South Africa
covers much of the southern tip of the
African continent and is a place where
numerous native African cultures as well
as former colonial populations have
converged resulting in a state of true
linguistic diversity South Africa has 11
official languages that have been
recognized in its Constitution since
1993 if that seems like a lot to you
you're probably right
South Africa is among the countries with
the largest number of official languages
at the national level number one is
actually neighbouring Zimbabwe with
sixteen official languages some of which
are also official in South Africa these
are the 11 official languages of South
Africa in order of most spoken to least
spoken as a first language Zulu Xhosa
Afrikaans English northern suto SWANA
southern suto Tsonga Swasey Venda and
underbelly over 99% of South Africans
speak one of these languages as a first
language all of these languages are
members of the southern Bantu branch of
the niger congo language family with the
exception of Afrikaans and English which
are Germanic languages brought to the
country by Europeans the Dutch first
arrived in what is now South Africa in
1652
establishing the Cape Colony in the
western portion of the country also
living in this area were native Khoisan
people and other Africans who spoke
Bantu languages the British seized
control of the Cape Colony in 1815 and
British settlers began to arrive the
Brewers the descendants of the original
Dutch settlers disliked many aspects of
British rule but one of them was the
Anglicization of the Cape Colony in the
attempt to force English on the Boers as
a medium of instruction in schools they
wanted to continue to use Dutch as their
medium of instruction and to continue
speaking their distinct dialect of Dutch
called Cape Dutch which would later
evolve into Afrikaans Boers began the
Great Trek migrating inland and creating
their own Boer Republic's in an area
more densely populated with African
tribes who spoke Bantu languages the
British later took control of the Boer
Republic's
and created the Union of South Africa in
1910 that eventually led to the creation
of the Republic of South Africa from
that point on there were two official
languages English and Dutch but Dutch as
spoken by the Boers
had evolved into a distinct language
called Afrikaans which replaced Dutch as
an official language in 1925 these two
colonial languages became the prestige
languages of South Africa and speakers
of other languages didn't really have
any say in the matter during the
apartheid era schools were segregated
not only based on race but also based on
mother tongue native speakers of English
and Afrikaans were taught in their
native language throughout their
schooling with second language
instruction in the other official
language black South Africans were
required to study in their mother tongue
for most of their primary school years
after which point they normally studied
in English but in 1974 the apartheid
government implemented a new policy
requiring instruction in black schools
to be conducted in a 50/50 split between
English and Afrikaans with the language
of instruction depending on the course
this was implemented without consulting
the black population in opposition to
this move led to the Soweto uprising of
1976 Afrikaans was seen as the language
of the oppressor since the apartheid
government was dominated by white
speakers of Afrikaans while English was
seen as a more cosmopolitan language
when apartheid ended in the early 1990s
a new constitution was written that
added nine additional African languages
as official languages in order to be
more inclusive of the entire population
the education system now is based on
freedom of choice with every individual
free to choose which of the 11 official
languages to be educated in for the
first part of their schooling as long as
there's sufficient demand for the school
to provide it that means that they don't
have to study in their mother tongue if
they don't want to let's take a look at
the map of South Africa when apartheid
was abolished the four provinces of
South Africa and the homelands enclaves
for African ethnic groups were abolished
and nine new provinces were created this
map shows the most dominant languages in
South Africa down to the local level you
can see that the 11 official languages
are clustered mainly in certain areas
and may predominate in certain provinces
but they don't correspond exactly to
provincial
orders you can see that Afrikaans
predominates in the West while the Bantu
languages predominate in the east and
English predominates in South Africa's
major urban centers as you can see
there's quite an intricate linguistic
situation in the eastern part of the
country so let's zoom in and look at the
African languages there as I mentioned
earlier the non-european languages of
South Africa are mainly members of the
southern Bantu branch of the niger congo
language family and these account for
about 70 percent of the population or
around 40 million people these southern
Bantu languages display some features
typical of the Bantu languages in
general they follow an SVO word order
like almost all Bantu languages their
tonal and they are largely agglutinative
and feature a large number of a fixes to
nouns and verbs most Bantu languages do
not have click sounds but many of these
southern Bantu languages do as a result
of contact with the Khoisan languages
the nine main southern Bantu languages
of South Africa can be further
categorized into three smaller
subdivisions the in goony languages the
SU toots wanna languages and the swih
Ranga or Tsonga group Venda forms its
own group so there are actually four
subdivisions including this one the in
goony branch of the southern Bantu tree
contains four of South Africa's official
languages Zulu Xhosa Swasey and in
dabeli the first two are the two most
spoken languages within South Africa as
a first language with Zulu representing
23% of the population and Xhosa
representing 16% of it the other two on
the other hand are spoken by only 2.5
percent in 2.1 percent respectively Zulu
is mainly spoken in kwazulu-natal and
most of em puma Lanka where Swasey and
underbelly are spoken as well Xhosa is
the majority language of the Eastern
Cape but has communities of speakers in
other provinces as well as other
official languages do the in goony
languages feature click consonants you
can hear one of them in the name of the
language Xhosa actually this is the
first time I've tried to pronounce a
click consonant so I may be pronouncing
the name of the language wrong from the
point of view of a native speaker but I
guess it's something like that Xhosa all
of the in goony languages are mute
intelligible to a large extent suited
SWANA the second largest of the southern
bantu branches is the suited SWANA
branch which has three languages within
it northern Sioux - representing 9.1% of
South Africa's population SWANA with 8%
and southern so - or simply Sioux - with
7.6% altogether they represent just
under a quarter of the population of
South Africa around thirteen point six
million people each of these three
languages serves as the majority
language in the province that it's most
widely spoken in southern suto in the
Free State SWANA in the northwest
province and there is also a significant
population of speakers in the northern
cape with which it shares a border and
northern Sioux - in Limpopo southern su
2 contains click consonants due to
contact with in goony languages while
some urban varieties of northern Sioux
to have in recent times been acquiring
clicks as well SWANA uses some click
sounds but only in interjections and
idiophones onomatopoeia for example and
like the in goony languages the suit
suits wanna languages are generally
mutually intelligible as well Tsonga or
Towanda although there are other
languages within this branch the only
one that has official status is Sangha
other languages of this group are
mutually intelligible and are oftentimes
considered part of the tongue the
language found in the Northeast
most of the Sangha speaking people live
in Limpopo or boom-boom malanga Sangha
features click sounds in just a few
words
another interesting phonological feature
is whistled sibilants consonants I
haven't been able to find a sample from
Tonga but here's a sample of a similar
sound in the shona language vinda one of
the less spoken of the official
languages in South Africa venda
comprises 2.4 percent of the population
or 1.3 million speakers who are almost
all concentrated on the northern border
of Limpopo near zimbabwe where it's
closest linguistic relatives live Venda
has no click sounds Afrikaans and
English the two Germanic languages of
South Africa Afrikaans and English
are the third and fourth most spoken
languages in the country with 13.5% and
9.6 percent of citizens speaking them as
their first language respectively people
outside of South Africa might assume
that native speakers of Afrikaans
are all white but that's not the case
it's the majority language in the
northern cape and western cape provinces
where most of the nation's colored
population or mixed-race population
lives and more than 75 percent of
colored South Africans speak Afrikaans
as their first language why is that it's
because they were part of the languages
development the origin of the coloured
community lies in the early days of the
Cape Colony when Dutch settlers
intermarried with indigenous koi song
women or slaves from Africa India and
Southeast Asia but they also interacted
linguistically and by learning Dutch
imperfectly as a second language they
influenced the direction of the Dutch
dialect that would evolve into Afrikaans
it's also spoken as a native language by
smaller numbers of the South Asian and
black South African populations and it's
spoken by over 60% of the white
population as a native language in total
it's the first language of about 13.5
percent of the population and it's
spoken by an even larger number as a
second language if you haven't seen my
language profile on Afrikaans from a
couple of years ago you can check it out
right here
English is spoken as a native language
mainly in the Western Cape how tang and
kwazulu-natal as these are where the
major cities can be found plus it's
widely spoken as a second language
English is the native language of 9.6
percent of the population including
around 36% of the white population it's
also the native language of most Indian
South Africans they speak with an accent
distinct from white South African
speakers of English during the apartheid
era interaction with whites was limited
which allowed their own distinct variety
of English to develop in isolation with
some phonological influences from Indian
languages I've mentioned the Kois on
languages a few times and you may be
wondering why they aren't on the list of
official languages
well the Khoisan were the first
indigenous people of much of South
Africa before the migration of Bantu
people's and later Europeans through
conflict with Bantu and Europeans
Khoisan were driven
to a much smaller area and now most
Khoisan live in the Kalahari Desert some
Khoisan intermarried with europeans and
became part of the colored population
while others died from conflict and
disease the end result of all this is
that only a very small population of
koyasan remain in South Africa and their
Khoisan languages are therefore not
widely spoken and are not official
languages choice on languages do not
form a single language family and are
not accepted as being related to each
other but all of them feature extensive
use of clicked consonants as I stated
before the click sounds used in Bantu
languages come from contact with Khoisan
languages the most widely spoken Khoisan
language in South Africa is Koya Koya or
nama with around 50,000 speakers this
language has an additional 250,000
speakers in neighboring Namibia there
are other Khoisan languages in South
Africa that are severely endangered like
Greek WA with only a few dozen speakers
remaining language in society in a
society with such linguistic diversity
it's inevitable that the majority of the
population will be bilingual or
multilingual most white and colored
South Africans are bilingual and English
and Afrikaans and a smaller number speak
one of the African languages as well
Indian South Africans speak English and
usually some Afrikaans and some speak in
Indian language as well typically older
people many black South Africans speak 3
4 5 or even more languages it's common
for them to speak their native African
language English and Afrikaans and one
or more other African languages they're
often able to speak the other languages
of the same subgroup as their native
language because they're closely related
and in many cases mutually intelligible
you may be wondering if the language is
within each subgroup are mutually
intelligible why are they considered
separate languages well what is a
language versus what is a dialect is a
murky issue as always but I think it's
partly because they each have their own
standardized variety and it's partly
because each one is associated with a
distinct ethnic group these days
business and politics are mostly
conducted in English and English is the
most common language of broadcast and
media for a long time
English and Afrikaans had
status as dual lingua Franca's of South
Africa but Afrikaans has been declining
in that regard that's partly due to the
stigma attached to Afrikaans as it's
seen as the language of apartheid in
addition to that education in South
Africa tends to lean towards English in
typical South African schools the first
three grades are taught in the students
mother tongue but after that school work
is conducted in either Afrikaans or
English schools can teach in the native
language longer but since secondary
school matriculation exams are only
conducted in English and Afrikaans
there's a strong motivation to switch to
one of those languages early on but
rather than Afrikaans most choose
English due to its utility and prestige
and in many cases families will forego
students being taught in their first
language and go straight into English to
jumpstart their proficiency but whether
this is a help or a hindrance is a
source of much debate the emphasis on
English and Afrikaans after the first
three or four years of initial schooling
is a lasting influence of the colonial
era today there are 11 official
languages and in theory and in law they
are equal but in practice English and
Afrikaans are still the most influential
languages at the national level and this
is still the case for now despite the
fact that Afrikaans has lost some of its
prestige the question of the day for
South Africans which languages do you
speak and in what situations do you use
them and for other people
how many official languages are there in
your country do you think that system
works well for your country be sure to
follow Lange focus on Facebook Twitter
and Instagram and once again thank you
to all of my wonderful patreon
supporters especially these ones on the
screen who are my top tier patreon
supporters many thanks to them as always
and to everyone thank you for watching
and have a nice day
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]